okay I'm gonna say something right
honest I'm honest I'm honest honest I'm
okay there's a lot of things in my life
I need to change because I'm almost 46
next month and I can feel my body
breaking down I can't move
well that's a good step I really can't I
can't I get up I can't get up geez and
it's like we're weighing down on all
aspects of my life I can feel it you
know my knees are [ __ ] I my knees are
broken I feel that like every year that
I feel like they're people of any age
they always say that like 2016 you're
like I'm just getting old I've said that
before this is real yeah I can't really
move I mean doctors usually say you
shouldn't smoke after 40
get on the [ __ ] jaw saying maybe I
have already irreversible no no no
because that's that's the kind of
behavior that well actually that I have
I'm like that too it's like it I'm so
far guy might as well just die of lung
cancer yeah that's how I thought it
would go out for sure I went to Panda
Express in Utah yeah two days ago right
and I after my meal I get the
combinations with the 300 yeah and then
um I opened up my fortune cookie okay oh
that's a sign that's like a metaphor of
her life no I think then in my head I'm
like I think I want to die oh oh no it
would say it would say you were gonna
die yeah you're not gonna die it's hard
for Asians to die it's some really
fucked-up [ __ ] has to happen I know um
with to be on a ferry boat or yeah what
does that what I mean Supremes died in a
fairy flower children I thought you
meant the way that people come in those
containers what I meant okay that's what
yeah that's more mild all right so what
do we
[Music]